hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well Martin Luther King has a short
sermon called unfulfilled hopes which is
about how we respond to what he calls
the tragic element in life which might
be greater in some person's lives or
situations than in others his own is a
prime example and that of the community
that he is trying to appeal to and
uplift and give some some encouragement
to through this sermon also some
guidance so he tells us that the sermon
brings us face to face with one of the
most persistent realities in Human
Experience what is that very few people
are privileged to live life with all of
their dreams realized and their hopes
fulfilled who here this morning has not
had to face the agony of blasted hopes
and Shattered Dreams and he's going to
use St Paul and the development of uh
Christianity and Christ himself as
examples of this but we could think
about many many others as well in other
traditions and so he begins with talking
about St Paul so St Paul had wanted to
go to Rome and to Spain and he does get
to one but he doesn't get to the other
and so the way he depicts it here uh
Paul writes these words to the Roman
Christians whenever I go into Spain I
will come onto you so he's got a dream
he's got a plan in other words uh he
says um whenever I go to Spain I will
stop by to see you this is one of the
high hopes of Paul's life this desire to
go to Spain and why to Spain it's on the
edge of the known world and to carry the
gospel to that distant land and on the
way he would stop to see the Christians
in Rome the capital city of the world so
he's got this big plan that he's telling
people about and what happens instead so
like Martin Luther King says well he
does get to go to to Rome but he doesn't
go to Rome to preach the gospel in the
way that he originally intended he's
going to die in Rome as a martyr he's
never going to get to go onto Spain
right so he says that uh he had to spend
his days in Rome in a little cell right
the story of Paul's life is the story
the tragic story of unfulfilled hopes
and Shadow dreams now he doesn't talk
about this here but we can say well but
look at all the other things that Paul
was able to accomplish he wrote all
these letters and went to all these
places sure but this was what he was
aiming at and Martin Luther King says
well this is not unique This Is Not
Unusual pretty much all of this all of
us are going to face something like this
he says in a real sense my friends this
is is the persistent story of Life
almost everybody here this morning has
started out on some distant trip to
reach some distant Spain to achieve some
distant goal to realize some distant
dream only to discover Life stopped
short of that and it could be anything
that you like we never got an
opportunity he says to walk as freem men
in the RS of Our Lives we ended up so
often confining a little cell that had
been built up around us by the forces of
circumstance this is the story of life
now the question is how should we
respond to this how should we regard
this and so he talks about you know the
Symphony of life and what we're talking
about here is sort of the grand Panorama
the if you like Universal and
historical he says that the early
Christian Church didn't overlook this
tragic element in life there is a cross
at the center of life and he says life
is not a great Symphony with all the
instruments playing harmoniously
together we will look at it long enough
we will discover there's a jangling
Discord so somebody's not playing quite
as they should people are out of time
the instruments are squeaking or too
loud or swallowed up by the other
instruments some people are actually
playing a different song than the one
that everybody else or most other people
think that we're supposed to be playing
and it can come to dominate we can go
further than this it's not just that
things are out of dis out of Accord out
of whack with each other he talks about
evil and so he tells us that um the
nagging
prehensile
tentacles of evil are always present
taking some of the meaning out of life
King knows there is genuine evil in the
world there is genuine evil in the
hearts and choices and actions and
policies of human beings he doesn't have
any problem saying that this is the case
and so what do we find out he says that
you know people are very frustrated
about it and they wonder if life has any
just
to it says um we've looked at the stars
we find ourselves saying these stars
shine from their cold and Serene and
passionless height totally indifferent
to the joys and Sorrows of us human
beings we begin to ask is uh the human
being a play thing of a callous nature
sometimes friendly sometimes inimical an
enemy right is man thrown out as a sort
of Orphan in the terrifying immensities
of space with nobody to guide him on and
nobody concerned concerned about him
he's saying this as a minister in a
church it's possible that nobody cares
and he says we come back to that point
of our text and our Prophet we come back
to the point of seeing in life that
there are unfulfilled hopes there are
moments when our dreams are not realized
and we should pause on that for a moment
he's going to pass on very quickly uh
into the rhetoric of this but dreams all
of us dream dream of something not just
when we're asleep and logic goes out the
window if we remember any of that we
have our dreams for ourselves we
envision ourselves in certain situations
it could be about success in the
workplace it could be about writing a
wonderful piece of music or a novel it
could be about loving and being loved by
somebody whose eye has uh you know
caught our own and all a lot of the time
these dreams are unfulfilled we could
even just dream about not living in pain
bodily pain humiliation being treated as
a person so he goes on and says we
discover in our lives that all pain is
never relieved we discover sooner or
later all hopes are never realized the
things that we hope for ourselves not
only for ourselves but that we hope for
others are often not realized as well or
if they are it's always only partial
it's never going to be exactly what we
wanted for them or for ourselves he says
we come to the point of seeing that no
matter how long we pray for them
sometimes and no h no matter how long we
cry out for a solution to our problems
no matter how much we desire it we don't
get the answer the only answer we get is
a fading echo of our desperate Cry of
our lonely cry and then he talks about
about Christ he says Jesus in The Garden
of Gethsemane praying the cup would be
removed from him but he has to drink it
with all of its bitterness and its pain
so even you know for Christianity this
superlative God man is going to be
disappointed frustrated have hopes
dreams not
fulfilled is there a solution to this
and we human beings do find as king is
to outline here a variety of solutions
some of which are not great Solutions
he's advocating one of these and warning
us about the other two so what is the
first there is the response of what he
calls
bitterness and this is a response that
pushes back against life but not
directly only indirectly through people
and other things which can be more
tangible more targeted so so he says
that some people get caught up in this
response they feel that the best way
they end up dealing with their
frustrations by taking out some of their
anger with the universe their anger with
life on other people and other things in
short they become mean and he says
you've seen Mean people you can do a
psych psychological analysis of them and
if you do that you will find that they
had some hopes and some dreams that were
unfulfilled and they are angry they are
bitter they bear a as he calls it
demonical grudge against life but
there's no way to Target life directly
to get your Grudge uh settled or
fulfilled and so he says that they seek
to solve their frustration by taking it
out on other people so he says sometimes
he's mean to his children or he's mean
to his wife or she's mean to to her
husband or mean to people around them
because you can't find life itself life
is intangible in a sense it's invisible
we don't see life we see manifestations
of life and you can never take life and
hit life and beat up on life so he
discovers he can't get life itself to be
done and pay back for what the universe
has done to him so he finds people that
are tangible and he finds things that
are tangible and he takes this
bitterness and this hate out on those
things the bitterness within and the
anger he becomes angry with the universe
and he fights the universe through
people and things so he says they react
with bitterness and
mercilessness and meanness and I I want
to pause on that mercilessness there
because another response that we're
going to jump right into is that of
withdrawal and we could talk about
people withdrawing and saying Ah that's
not my problem that other people are
suffering Mercy is a response to the
suffering of others
so this is a different kind of bad
response to the suffering of others
instead of just saying H that's not my
problem it says screw you you've got it
coming to you I hope you suffer even
more so that's you know kind of an
aggressive response another possibility
the response as he says of
withdrawal he says they may withdraw
completely into the M elves they
withdraw completely and they build walls
around themselves they don't allow
anyone to penetrate and they developed
attachment into a neat and Fine Art and
why are they doing this so that they
don't feel the pain so that they don't
have to register that things are the way
that they are and he says now it's kind
of interesting there's a bifurcation
here says that they're neither happy nor
unhappy just indifferent they they don't
take a stance on anything they pull
themselves away from it hiding
themselves within their own self but is
this really so
indifferent Martin Luther King says that
they are fighting the universe not with
bitterness but with a silent hate they
withdraw from people that withdraw from
the world they withdraw from everything
and turn totally within this they feel
is a solution to the problem why do they
withdraw because they're not going to
give anything to the universe they're
not going to go against it they're not
going to hurt people deliberately but
they're sure not going to help anybody
or allow themselves to be
reached the third response he talks
about at greater length is that of
creative will as he calls it he says it
involves the exercise of a great and
dynamic will now this and the examples
that he gives might lead us to think ah
well maybe I don't have the resources to
do that I'm just a little person I don't
have a great or you know what I would
call Dynamic will I'm not even sure what
that would look like except perhaps in
these distant examples of of wonderful
people who overcome you know whatever
adversity they're running into but
that's that's just not me and king would
say oh no that is you all of us do have
the potential for this greatness is not
some sort of Benchmark it is instead
what you're going to do with that
faculty of will so he says this is the
individual who stands up in his
circumstances and stands up amidst the
problem faces the fact his hopes are un
fulfilled recognizes reality but what
does this individual do instead of
saying screw you world I'm going to get
back at you or screw you world you're
not going to touch me this individual
says I have one thing life left life has
beaten it down it has broken away from
me many things sometimes my physical
body but at least it has left me with a
will and I will assert this and I refuse
to be stopped the will is an interesting
thing some people would like to say we
don't have a will but it's clear that we
do make choices and however conditioned
those choices may be we do have some
degree of agency and freedom and taking
itself and deciding what to do with
itself that is something that you know
for a long time including the people
that King himself has studied like for
example Augustine great philosopher of
the will realized that the will is
something that directs
itself so he goes on and he says even if
Rome and Spain are blocked off my
itinerary I refuse to be stopped I will
go somewhere else and this is the man
who stands up in the greatness of life
he discovers the power and the
creativity of human will and he faces
any circumstance with the power and
force of his will now that makes it
sound like you just kind of like oh you
need you need to just like decide and
everything's going to go great no King
talks about dogged determination
which means that you're probably not
going to win you're not going to succeed
every single time and the successes that
you enjoy will probably be partial
they'll include elements of failure and
not being completely filled right he
says every now and then life will beat
me push me to this side and that side
but I will stand up to it I will not be
stopped and then he uses this
interesting example of taking a flight
uh across the the Atlantic flying to
London from New York and going one way
it's quicker than going the other way
why because there's a headwind going one
way which helps you along and there's a
Tailwind or actually We've Got It
reversed there's a Tailwind helping you
out that is behind you and then a
headwind uh taking you the other way
that is is interfering with you well
sometimes life is like that you start
something out it seems quite easy you've
got a Tailwind you're struggling against
resistance the whole time well you got a
headwind and King will say that plane
itself is actually showing what we're
talking about here it still gets to New
York right even though it has to go
against a headwind um and so he says you
know we we can apply this to to
everybody and he talks about the
condition which makes perfect sense of
uh
African-Americans and the struggles that
they have to face there are many
headwinds and he says that um you know
this doesn't prevent people from
exercising a creative will and what is
the result of this he says these people
by their creative Dynamic will this is
really quite important gave to the world
something to keep it going and instead
of saying screw you world they said I'm
going to respond to the challenges that
you're placing in front of me the
frustrations The Dashing of my hopes the
interference with my dreams the failure
to provide me with any sort of solution
I'm going to respond to this by doing
what I'm doing and that will give
something back to life and again
remember life exists in its
manifestations this means giving
something back to other
people so he gives you a few examples of
this the spiritual the O only original
and creative music in this nation he
calls it but he also says it gave to the
world generations of young men and young
women who have made marvelous
contributions and he gives you a whole
bunch of examples of these people and he
says out of these black men and these
black women came something that keeps
the generations going if they had turned
to the first method of bitterness it
wouldn't have come if they' withdrawn
and turned to silent hate it wouldn't
have come but it came because of the
creativity of the will and the dynamic
quality of it and the determination to
stand up amidst all those forces amidst
the darkness of human circumstance now
what does that mean there is a continual
intergenerational we could even say
establishment of community and tradition
we we recognize that this is not just
you know an age-old problem but that we
exist within a matrix in which many
people have had this response of
creative will many of them famous people
but many of them humble people who just
did what they needed to do perhaps in
our families perhaps in our communities
and that we can continue on by adopting
a similar response which won't look the
same as their response because we're in
different
circumstances and he's going to make one
other point he says strangely enough
when you come to this point you don't
worry about suffering you don't die
because you don't get to Spain you come
to see suffering might make you stronger
and bring you closer to God now he's
talking to a religious audience here of
course it's a sermon but we could easily
think about this this is uh you know
revealing to us uh whatever it is that
you find
Transcendent and so his his charge to
people is discover this go out a new
into the experiences of life I assure
you you will meet your Spain in the
sense that you will never get there you
might get to your Rome as a prisoner not
as a free man but if you have the power
and dynamics of a human will nothing in
all this world can stop you why because
you refuse to be stopped you have the
dogged determination to exist and the
courage to be and this is where it ends
having outlined the problem and then
these three potential Solutions and
advocating for the response of creative
will
that